it's a brand new year and we're going to
talk about the first new releases of
2016 let's start it off with assassin's
creed chronicles India an upcoming
downloadable game available on ps4 xbox
one pc and Vita but you'll see that the
game doesn't look like most of the
entries in the franchise being set on a
2.5 d plane and all it's part of a
trilogy pack with assassin's creed
chronicles china and the same title with
russia players use stealth tactics like
hiding from enemies and shadows and
climbing areas that are highlighted with
more color this is coming out on the
12th next up gemini heroes reborn for
xbox one you combine superpowers like
telekinesis and time travel using your
skill and wits to battle your way
through an enemy filled secret facility
called the quarry you gotta save your
abducted friend and solve a deep family
mystery that's pretty much all I know
but it's basically got that whole
gravity gun thing going for it except
it's your hand instead of a gun cool
that's out on the 12th also coming to
Xbox one but also ps4 is gone home
console edition set in the year nineteen
ninety-five it's about exploring a
mansion in Portland you examine
household items to find out more about
the family but you probably already knew
that because this game has won a bunch
of awards and you've probably heard
people arguing about whether or not it's
a game you can find out for yourself on
the 12 next up is Tharsis turn-based
strategy game in space with dice and
cannibalism it puts you in control of
humanity's first manned mission to Mars
that surprise goes horribly wrong gotta
guide the crew through food shortages
disasters harsh environments you know
space stuff and you got to maintain your
sanity sounds like fun that's out on ps4
and PC on the 12th
but hey if you want one of the most
beautiful tactical role-playing games
I've ever seen you should check out the
banner saga which is now on ps4 and xbox
one if you didn't plan it on PC it
centers on the return of the dredge
which is a warlike race that hates us
humans basically walk with your army
trying to find weaknesses and deal with
a ton of difficult decisions that will
shape the fate of the war it's a pretty
good game and it is gorgeous so if you
like that style you can pick it up on
the 12 but if you're interested in a
very heavy heartfelt story you could
consider that dragon cancer the game is
based on a family's emotional experience
of raising their son Joel who's
diagnosed with terminal cancer at 12
months old and though only given a short
time to live he continued to survive for
the next four years this is a true story
and it will be tough to get through this
but it looks very real and very honest
and very human you can pick that up on
PC on the twelfth and finally there's
dragons dogma dark arisen on PC and
expanded an enhanced version of Dragon's
Dogma this version includes the original
game with a new zone to explore called
bitter black isle incorporated into this
version was all the downloadable content
created for the original release a new
fast travel system as well as new items
weapons armor and quests that's out on
the 15th so that's it for this week let
me know what you're interested in
picking up release dates are based on
retailer listings and they're subject to
change I'll see you next week